alors même si les relations sont plutôt
difficiles entre la france et l'iran
depuis 35 ans on voit bien que de
nombreuses marques françaises sont
présentes ici et n'ont jamais ces sept
se vendent elles plaisent à une certaine
clientèle et vous allez voir que des
normands sont présents en iran depuis
les années 2000 et même bien avant dans
ce bhv de téhéran on trouve donc dû
mauviel authentique façonné à villedieu
les poêles dans la baie du mont saint
michel
depuis 2008 ce riche businessman iranien
à la tête du puissant groupe bayard en
importe
régulièrement présent aux états unis
comme aux émirats il peut payer
directement ses clients sans passer par
les banques soumises aux contraintes de
l'embargo il travaille avec des français
des italiens et bien d'autres pour un
chiffre d'affaires annuel à faire pâlir
m
le groupe d'aia estime qu'il y à 2
millions de consommateurs potentiels
pour ses magasins en iran des clients
qui aiment le c'est la plus belle
nouveauté c'est celle que je veux
consommateurs aisés mais vous savez en
même temps en iran ou de marièrent c'est
vraiment un événement dans les familles
et on ne gâte les jeunes mariés la
famille du marié si elle peut achète la
maison où la voiture est du côté de la
mariée en charge de tout ce qu'il faut
lui dans des clientes aisées qui se
laisse envoûter par le luxe français
mais la french touch a ses limites la
normandie le camembert
elles n'en n'ont jamais entendu parler
non désolé je ne connais rien de votre
culture alimentaire ou des régions
françaises des futures mamans qui
n'imagine donc même pas qu'elles
donneront sûrement dans quelques temps
du les normands à leur bébé
car depuis près de quinze ans maintenant
la coopérative d'isigny centenaire
fournit le marché iranien
son responsable commercial a profité de
cette délégation pour aller sonder
lui-même le rayonnement de ses produits
en pharmacie
là c'est super
de voir là les conditions réelles
le marché et puis aussi ressentir la vie
en iran là viendra accompagné d'une
interprète
il demande à l'improviste sont les
conditionner ici sous le nom de bio 1100
clients iraniens
alors aujourd'hui on peut estimer qu'on
nourrit à peu près un bébé sur un peu
plus d'un but et sur trois en viande
l'interprète nous expliquera que cette
boîte là est très à la mode
on peut dans certains milieux la
préférez sans souci au géant nestlé
jamais pendant l'embargo isigny sainte
mère n'a cessé de vendre à l'iran
mais pour aller au delà des poudre
infantile
il va falloir attendre encore un peu le
beurre et la crème fraîche
non pas vraiment d'avenir ici pour le
moment